el gobernador de Florida ron de santis
ya oficializado su candidatura a las
primarias por el partido republicano
para ser el candidato de las próximas
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 aquí
en Estados Unidos el sistema de Twitter
donde iba a anunciar su candidatura en
una conversación con elons ha colapsado
y numerosos usuarios han reportado
fallas en la plataforma por lo que se ha
un poco sin embargo minutos
antes de que comenzara el evento de
santis había subido un vídeo en el que
denunciaba que las fronteras de Estados
Unidos son un desastre que el crimen
había aumentado en las ciudades del país
y que por culpa de las políticas de la
Casa Blanca de biden las familias
estaban sufriendo en todo el país ha
defendido que debe prevalecer el sentido
común y ponía como ejemplo el estado de
Florida como modelo de éxito que se
puede extrapolar al resto del país el
gobernador llega con un catálogo de
leyes ultraconservadoras que ha aprobado
en las últimas semanas en Florida como
la ley del aborto que lo restringe de 15
semanas la ley Para aportar armas es
libremente o la ley anti inmigrante que
criminaliza con hasta 15 años de prisión
a quienes transporten a indocumentados
en los exteriores de este hotel donde de
santis ha participado en la sesión de
Twitter numerosos activistas se han
concentrado y siguen aquí para protestar
por estas políticas que han causado una
gran controversia en todo el país y para
oponerse también a esta candidatura
ahora empieza una carrera para las
primarias su principal contrincante es
el expresidente Donald Trump que ya lo
ha criticado diciendo que no está en
sintonía con los votantes y que de
santis no tiene un plan de gobierno
además las encuestas tampoco lo
favorecen Trump supera de santis en más
de 20 puntos también se verá las caras
con Niki Halley la exgobernadora de
Carolina del Sur con Team Scott el
primer senador de es negro de Estados
Unidos en más de un siglo o con asas
gobernador de Arkansas